what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today I'm about to show you
guys my interview my my first time ever meeting
Tom clementieff who plays mantis in the Guardians
of the Galaxy franchise I wanted to first
start this video off by saying thank you to
everyone who is the supporter of this channel
because I'm aware I'm just some doofus on the
internet so the fact that I get to have this
sit down with an actress who I really admire
I get to ask her questions that I genuinely want
to know the answer to is just plain and simple a
privilege that wouldn't be possible without all of
you so a sincere thank you we got to talk about a
lot of great things I think you guys have really
enjoyed especially if you guys are a fan of her
work the second thing I wanted to say a thank you
for is thank you to everyone who bought tickets
for the special live event that I am doing this
coming Sunday May 7th with Christian harloff and
John campia at Flappers comedy in Burbank see a
couple months ago we United to do a live spoiler
talk for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania sold
out really fast it was such a great event got
to meet so many of you guys after the show but
especially talk to many of you during the show
it was seriously a blast one of the best moments
of my YouTube career we thought we'd do it again
for a Marvel movie that we all three genuinely
loved and let's go Forest Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. we've still got some in-person tickets
available so there's a link in the description
box if you guys want to come last time it was only
in person but if you can't make it in person for
this one you can now stream it from anywhere in
the world we have pay-per-view links available
as well both links in the description box thank
you again can't wait to meet all of you who are
going to be attending in person it's going to
be a an absolute blast enjoy the video guys
and we are growling uh say the camera yeah
this is my first in-person junkers actually
your laces are like undone are you okay uh
yeah I'll just trip during this interview
an outlet for us my name is Greg Alba and I'm
with uh real rejects hi pom pleasure to meet
you nice to meet you too I know you've been
hearing all day I want you to know I mean it
more than everyone else I love the hell out of
this movie I loved it so much I've rewatched
all the Guardians movies and the holiday special
and and then of course this movie and I feel like
one of the biggest earmarks about the portrayal of
mantis that you have is she she can go from being
very soft-spoken to then having this like deep
monstrous voice right yes and I know a lot of
times that's played for comedic laughs but mantis
has a lot of like pain in her as well so I was
wondering even though it's played generally for
comedy is any of that choice consciously imbued
in representing the pain within her oh I didn't
think of that but so it's it's a it's a good one
I mean I feel like sometimes also for people
who are like shy you know they're like more
soft-spoken and sometimes there's a burst of
you know of something stronger and it needs to
come out you know in in fermented she gains in
uh in confidence to in self-confidence so yeah
some she needs to to stand up for herself so it
yeah she said comes out of her you know but it
brings comedy too it's very satisfying yeah you
feel you feel like you're far it happens yeah
I can imagine as you know one of the best parts
about playing mantis is that because she's such
a highly sensitive empath that when you have
like a a scene like where you're seeing or
scene partner one of the best parts is you get to
just literally feed off of what they're giving you
and let that kind of guide the scene let that
guy how you play the scene so I was wondering
is there any actor in particular in this room I
know everyone's amazing in this franchise but is
there any actor in particular that you find you
find it the easiest to connect with and play off
of them just feeling their emotions oh my God
there's such incredible actors and beautiful
human beings that they're all really easy to
connect with you know and I care deeply uh
um for them you know so there's not like one
one person in particular it's I can't choose
choose now die [Laughter] that's actually
the best answer that to give for that when
I was watching the holiday special and then also
watching this ego is mentioned briefly in this
movie and so much of mantis's Journey has been
you know her coming into her own and not living
a life of servitude by the way it reminds me of
Kurt Russell I I love Kurt but he like called me
his bug daughter or like buggy daughter oh really
it's so cute very different Dynamic than what the
actual ego character is like yeah he's so nice in
real life when the movie he's so evil but I was I
was wondering when I was re-watching Guardians 2 I
was thinking that there was probably so much like
you know character history and memories that
you probably had to create that we didn't get to
learn about but now it's been such a long journey
does any of the character memory Arsenal that you
created from Guardians 2 all those years ago did
any of that factor in before you did any scenes in
this Guardians movie I do I don't really work that
way creating memories and things like that I just
um you know have conversations with James
and then I just said create my own little
world and way of moving and um you know I
connect with you know real emotions and I
just I don't know it's my little like dense
in my brain I don't know how to explain it's
awesome but like you know I'm not like method
or I'm not like thinking about the character
for hours I just I don't know I just like
listen to music that inspires me sometimes
I'm inspired by the praying mantis I watched
videos of praying mantises dancing or fighting
um I just think of myself when I was a child
too like how would I would speak and how I
would react and um yeah and sometimes it's just
like you know saying the words um and savoring
each word and also being being not an English
speaker at first you know I'm French it's just
like I think it's it's just creates a different
tone in the voice in the the way I say things and
the different music so I guess I don't know that's
how I created the alien I guess so it's just like
letting go and going with the instincts the whole
time yeah oh that's a beautiful answer to have
um one of my favorite Parts in this whole thing
that you have with the Guardians movies is of
course like the interaction that you can have
with with Drax which I'm pretty good probably
asked about a lot I think if anyone does a Google
search on you they'll see that you're one of like
the toughest people working in Hollywood today
as soft as you are is it also like you're like
a daredevil of sorts but at the same time there's
so much ribbing and making fun of that you guys do
with each other that does it ever get to a point
where actually I got two full questions it ever
get to a point where the Improv can you do you
guys ever get offended has it ever gone too far or
are you guys even harsher to each other when the
camera's not rolling when making oh my God never
Dave is such a sweetheart he would like never
know we have so much fun I want him like to like
say that I'm disgusting and ugly so hilarious you
know and yeah and sometimes like does he call me
an [__] or something at some point it's so funny
oh that's amazing it's hard to not like not like
to not laugh during the scene you know so I have
to like be serious and be like in character you
know yeah of course well uh yeah I love this movie
uh I feel like you've just gotten progressively
more amazing than each installment oh thank you
so much I just wanted to say at the end of the
holiday special especially on my re-watch I'm like
man that does bring me to tears Europe oh my God
I mean you know it's James Gunn's talent to be
able to um uh to create such a beautiful balance
between deep emotion and entertainment and and
very very funny scenes as well you know it's just
I don't know it's it's very special for sure of
course of course well thank you so much for your
time I had a really busy day but thank you for
being so generous thank you thank you so much
foreign